hello and welcome to our webinar today
on five advanced conversion rate
optimization tips that will skyrocket
your conversions here's a preview of
some what we lock we'll be talking about
today first how to get your website
visitors to take action
what is conversion rate optimisation and
why it matters how to perform CRO
testing like a pro how to leverage your
web analytics to improve conversions and
finally how to implement personalized
experiences on your website now it's my
pleasure to introduce you to our guest
and CRO expert Lee Locke how are you
very much than tactic to be here truly
honored and so thank you for the very
warm welcome now we would get to the
nitty-gritty of conversion rate
optimisation I want to tell you a little
bit about myself my accolades intial I'm
a digital content specialist and digital
marketing expert with over 14 years of
experience I work with enterprises SMEs
startups as well as nonprofits helping
them grow and generating ROI their
online marketing I receive various
accolades over the years including being
one of the top 20 women's social media
power influences by Forbes as well as
being going to the social influencer set
of Europe by Oracle but I don't want to
spend too long talking about myself
so let's instead get to the tips and
advice that will help you turn your web
traffic into sales and conversions
conversion rate optimization is a
process that essentially means
increasing the percentage of website
visitors they take a desired action
starting with micro conversions such as
viewing a particular piece of content
and leading up to all kinds of
conversions like filling out a form on
your website or buying an offer in other
words is a process that helps you
increase the value of your website
traffic by enabling your visitors to
take the actions you want them to take
it can be something as simple as
changing the color of your
call-to-action button or improving your
website speed by a second or less or it
can be a bigger project like a
completely vamping of your website
design to give you an idea of what
impact a small change can have on your
results listen to this scary statistic a
one-second delay on your mobile pages
speed can mean your conversions will
drop by as much 20 percent but I'll get
into all of these specifics later on in
this webinar it's important to
understand that this is a continuous
process not something that you do once
or twice and then forget about customers
are constantly changing their behavior
and their preferences so it is essential
to continue optimizing your website in
order to continue growing your
conversion rate after the wives of thing
there's a lot of reasons why you should
really care about conversion rate
optimisation and why you should make it
a priority as far as your marketing and
sales efforts go for one thing it gives
you more bang for your buck the higher
your conversion rate afterworld the
higher your revenue will be the more
people you convert without you having to
pay for extra ads the more leads you
have in your list and the more layers
you have in your list the more of them
you'll be able to convert into actual
paying customers not to mention when you
maximize the value of your existing
track you can cut down on your online ad
and PPC spending you won't need to
invest in more aunt in more promotional
channels just so you can get more
traffic and ultimately more these rather
you're making the most out of the
traffic you're already driving to your
website whether through paid organic now
so that you can generate more leads on
it essentially it's a one of the most
cost effective way to maximize your
existing website traffic if you have a
low conversion rate of under two percent
actually a sign of alarm a sign that
your business is stagnating or even
struggling ideally you want to get a
conversion rate of at least four percent
on your web and if you're not getting
that much and it's quite possible that
you're unable to do work with scale your
business so now I want to ask you
what is your website and your landing
pages current conversion rate write it
down and next week write down your new
conversion rate goal a goal to be
reached by the end of this year one of
the biggest most well known examples of
conversion rate optimisation at its best
is Barack Obama's re-election campaign
back in 2012 his campaign was so
successful it surpassed everyone else
who came before him he also just the
first African American US president but
he was also the first-ever candidate
that was sieved 1 billion in donations
out of which a staggering 690 million
will raise through online donation so
exactly how did he manage to get these
impressive results obviously there was a
lot of factors that counted towards his
reelection well when it comes to the
donations
he raised online much of it is because
of the campaign's conversion rate
optimization strategy a car rush one of
his campaign major contributors on today
how do they do it quite simply by
running a lot of tests and I do mean a
lot their campaign run over 500
different tests on that Obama donation
website as well as on their different
adding pages which led to some
incredible results for one thing their
online donation conversions increased a
staggering 49% and certainly their
online signup conversions increased by
as much of a hundred and sixty one
percent to give you an example of the
types of changes the Obama campaign
implemented to these donations here's a
screenshot of the two versions of their
donation form now as you can see here
just by revamping the donation form and
essentially making it as quick as
possible to donate they managed to
increase online donations and conversion
by 5% add that up to all the other
little and big changes they made
throughout the website landing pages and
that's how the campaign managed to be so
successful
so what can you learn from this campaign
conversion optimization strategy and
other similar successful endeavors
how can you to improve your website
conversion rates
time after time well that's what we're
here to talk about so let's get started
what is the CRO process look like
exactly if there's one thing that
defines conversion rate optimisation is
it testing lots and lots for testing
just like in the previous example with
Barack Obama's re-election campaign the
secret to their success was that they
were constantly trying out different
variations of their landing pages or
design to help them reach their goals
faster I will be telling you all about
CRO testing throughout this webinar as
it's closely interlinked with most
Bureau strategies but first here's or
the conversion rate optimisation process
should look like as you can see there
are several stages to this process
discovery premise prioritization testing
and animal the first stage is the
discovery phase before you start
optimizing you need to know who your
audiences you need to learn as much as
possible about your audience so that you
can then use that knowledge to optimize
their browsing experience and therefore
grow your conversion you need to
establish who exactly forms your website
audience and which of the uses you want
to target and convert things like their
age is the occupation their gender their
location and other similar data that
will help you put together audience
persona not only that you also need to
study the particularity of their
behavior once on your website what pages
delivers at the most which pages make
them want to abandon your website what's
the pivot path are they taking and are
there the path that you want them to
turn focus on collecting as much data as
possible at this stage as a more dating
hat the better equipped you will be to
make the changes needed
in order to improve your conversion
another essential part of this discovery
and research base is to identify the
exact areas of your website that need
include it might be a page or form isn't
converting or it might even be that you
need to develop a better path to help
visitors get to the stage where they're
converging the second stage is the
primitive stage you know who your target
audience is
you know what areas need improving now
you need to come up with the ideas on
how exactly you can start improving
essentially is all about listing all the
different premises that you're allowed
to try out or test in order to boost
your conversion for example a premise
could be something like if I would use
the number of fields and questions in
the lead gentle I will boost my form
conversions by 5% can it be done well
that's where testing comes in after you
come up with your premises it's time to
start prioritizing the work you'll be
carrying out at this stage you should
have quite a few things that you want to
test you can't do them all at once or it
will be impossible to tell which changes
actually affected your result tap some
of the changes you're proposing to make
might happen on the same page on your
website or either the same element on
the page so take the time to consider
which changes of the most important and
which changes have a biggest chance of
making a real difference to your
conversion rate obviously these are the
ones you should start with
you
next comes our testing and experimental
stage the name of which is pretty
self-explanatory at this stage you know
exactly what you want to test and why so
you can get started as your priorities
set in the previous stage you'll be
leveraging a be testing a multivariate
testing technique to see which hyper
pieces turned true and which don't
and last concert animal stage the stage
in which you evaluate your results and
figure out which changes make a positive
difference and which don't
this stage will intertwine with the
testing stage as you should continue to
test variables while measuring the
results of your previous tests at the
same time
one of the best ways to make sure you
achieve your conversions over doubling
or even tripling your conversion rate in
two years Roberts Roberts here darling
six principles of persuasion
these principles were first established
in the 18th and they continued to be
known as the standard for encouraging
sale the third principle scarcity is
something you've probably noticed your
whole life in ads online and also
offline when you use words like only a
few left
limited time offer or final sale you are
giving your visitors that final push
needed to make the decision to buy
consistency the second principle is a
tiny bit more complex what it means is
in order to turn your knees into regular
custom it's best to start small by
getting them to commit to something
floor like downloading a free gift or
giving away their emanager
I'm going committed in this small way
your consistent marketing you are
increasing the likelihood that they will
move on from that small step to make
purchases or even better become one of
your regular customers another way of
persuading your visitors to find from
you is with reciprocation the thing is
when you give a visitor a benefit such
as a gift I can evoke or useful
checklist they're much more likely to
return a favor in the future and buy
from
next their social proof castle reviews
are extremely important people as
evidenced by the existence of so many
different customer review platforms like
TripAdvisor or Yelp not to mention some
of the biggest e-commerce websites like
Amazon and eBay who heavily rely on
customer review to make more sales make
sure to add your own customer reviews
and testimonials to your website and
particularly to your landing page
most people are much more likely to
trust the reviews of other clients
rather than your promises it's not just
customers that can help you make more
sense if you want to boost your
authority lead endorsements make
influential people in your niche when
you first think of endorsement you're
probably thinking of stars and famous
people that however is not feasible for
most businesses instead focus on getting
the support of social influencers in
your industry or knowing specialists and
for ages the last print support is
likely the idea behind this musical is
pretty straightforward
the more come online soon the more
likely it is there buy from you while in
the bricks and mortar world is quite
easy to establish a personal connection
as you deal with actual people directly
in the online world is a bit more
difficult the best way to connect with
your visitors on a more human level is
to create a well-thought-out about Us
page where you show the people behind
the business complete with your story
your goals or passions and personal
information about you that will help
Indian visitor
how exactly do you learn what's needed
about your website visitors how do you
gather all the data you need about them
and about their browsing shopping habits
so that you can boost your conversion
way the answer is pretty simple
again very complex analytic analytic and
more analytic there is so much to learn
on your analytics especially if you
leverage various methods at all
not just the basic Google Analytics
report essentially analytics allow you
to learn about your visitors an audience
as well as help you understand what
their behavior is like so you can
ultimately change and improve the
browsing and use experiences even
without changing any actual content on
your website the past get that or I
tracking tools are extremely useful
tools that basically show you what users
look at on your pages what they click on
what they don't even notice even though
you want and so on
for example here's what a heat map look
like courtesy of conversion tool crane B
egg this type of technology provides a
lot of value from the arrow perspective
I've it allows you to see exactly why
your pages aren't performing as well as
they should and how you can further
improve landing pages product pages lead
generation form and call to action in
order to seduce your conversion rates of
these pages as well there are several
ways to use heat maps depending on which
tools you use with it each one has its
own set of features some even allowing
you to see details about the actual
people visiting your website such as
their company and even some contact
details in case you want to reach out
directly if a high qualified high
quality leads visit your website that
said we're here to talk about conversion
rate optimization but here's how you can
leverage heat maps to help improve your
conversion rate determine the
effectiveness of your call to action
heat map can tell you if your cause to
action are visible enough on your page
and whether you need to make some
changes to get more people to engage
with your call-to-action button for
example scroll map show you how much
people tend to scroll on a specific web
page if your call to action with after
that mark you need to move it up so that
more your visitors will see it and eye
tracking heat map can tell you whether
your call to action is truly visible the
heat map will also tell you which areas
of your page attract the most idle
neutrally so that you can move your call
to action around orders to improve
visibility determine whether there are
any elements distracting your visitor
heat map can also show you whether too
many other and unnecessary animals are
taking up people's attention and
therefore moving it from the element you
want to notice such as a call-to-action
button a link or even a specific piece
of content such as a product video
understand how users interact with your
content
content to be a very powerful conversion
tool as it helps build trust keep people
on your website for longer and in some
cases encourage the visitors to take
certain actions but how much do your
visitors actually care about your
content which part interests them how
they behave on your blog or other pages
that include content and that's why heat
maps come in Mouse tracking scroll maps
and so on show you which part actually
interests your visitors and which don't
so that you can then use this knowledge
to improve your content as well as the
pages where your content results
improving website design heat maps might
also help you notice on your website
apply for other emotion it difficult to
explore your website so make the user
experience unpleasant in any way and
unnecessary web page elements that bring
nothing to the table the more you
improve this experience your visitors
the better your results will be to cover
elements that are distracting visitors
from taking edge you might think that
extra lead generation form you added to
your page or booth conversion but what
if instead is distracting people from
your much more important call to action
button on the same page use heat maps to
examine all of these elements on your
pages and find out which are helping and
which are distracting users from taking
the desired action improve shopping cart
conversion similarly people might get
distracted by certain elements from your
website when shopping on your website a
really good example of this is the North
Bay notice the kind of heat maps that
their online shoppers are getting
distracted from the shopping cart by a
banner so instead of clicking on their
car I'm finishing their shopping lot of
users clicked on the banner instead
which took them completely out of the
check check out path what was the
solution
quite simply change all the location of
the checkout button on the page this led
to 20
1% increase in click-through rate to the
checkout page for the brand discover any
dead ends sometimes it's not users
getting distracted that's the problem
but the fact that there's nowhere else
to go from specific webpage for example
let's say someone with a blog post on
your blog through to the end that they
cut them and no other relevant
navigational options at the end of that
post they are banned on the website then
and there that could be a big
opportunity loss and that the only one
in many you hate map to discover which
of your pages are so-called dead ends so
that you can add call-to-action and
other navigational paths and keep people
on the website for longer and preferably
converting in order to become a winner
conversion rate optimisation you need to
master testing testing is at the basis
of any successful conversion rate
optimization strategy it's how you find
out what works and what doesn't
which changes lead to a higher
conversion rate and which don't have an
effect or even work of a negative
although I feel like I should get this
out of the way now even if a change
you're testing needs a negative effect
don't worry that's why it's called
testing something to learn and some
won't but as long as you clearly know
which change lead to do those results
you can also reverse it also worth
pointing out this is very much an
ongoing process and that in order to
keep growing your conversion rate and
sales
you should also continue to test new
strategies and content as Amazon founder
and CEO Jeff Bezos keeps it if you've
double the number of experiments you do
tell you you're going to double your
inventively
what dangers is not to both my view is
there's no bad time to innovate and a
while there's no denying that Jeff Bezos
knows what you're talking about
Alice on has been constantly changing
over the years from the look and feel of
the call-to-action button the content
displayed for each user who visit before
you start testing anything you
firstly to establish exactly what you're
going to test and prioritize the most
important test of that one I'll be
giving you some recommendations on what
to test soon before that though I want
to talk about one of the questions that
I get asked the most about this topic
how long should you wait and start
measuring the results of your test and
applying the knowledge there's no
straightforward answer however rather it
depends a lot on the volume of traffic
you get your website if your website
gets a lot of traffic then it's best to
measure your results by specific amounts
of visitors such as that every 10,000
visitors if on the other hand your
website doesn't get that many visitors
then it's best to do it by timetables
preferably at least a couple of weeks or
even a month each change to give people
enough time to interact with that web
page so that you can gather enough data
and make a truly informed decision now
let's go to into a be testing and how to
use a be testing to take your website to
new heights
ad testing also known as split testing
there's a cro process that involves
setting two versions of a webpage or
landing sending an equal amount of
traffic to these pages so that you can
then monitor the conversions means that
each variation of your page for example
you might want to test a call-to-action
button on one of your landing page in
this case you would create two versions
of this page where one page of the
original design but the second variation
has a different call to action it can be
placement of the CTA button colors the
wording you use and so on up completely
up to you once the test is finished you
can measure the conversion for each
version of the page and pick a winner
based on the results once done you can
continue running as many tests as you
want or need for example you might want
to continue testing even more changes to
the call-to-action button at the first
variation you try to use a different
color for the button and then the next
test you can run could be the wording of
the future
another option is multivariate testing
but personally after so many tests on
over the years I found that a B tests
tend to be a better solution of the
answer is much clearer with multivariate
test it can be difficult to pinpoint
which exact changes made the difference
but with a B test there's only one
change at a time it's much easier to
identify which elements that are real
different and which don't
now before you start testing anything
from your website consider the
conversion rate optimization process
first and you might remember from
earlier before you start the
experimentation but you also need to
bring a few hypotheses to the table what
kind of test do you think you should run
which elements do believe have the
biggest impact on website visitors and
should therefore be tested once you've
made a list of these testing result you
can start prioritizing choosing the best
test Department at this page I would
recommend collaborating with other
members of the team as well as from
copywriters to web designing their input
can help you discover new possible tab
and variations that you should try full
of help you prioritize the test you're
going to run first once you start
testing don't be put off by inconclusive
results or variants that produce even
worse results on before it's a natural
part of the process it's important to
understand it is all about them and
learning sometimes evolves from the
state the important thing here is not to
avoid anything but rather to learn from
them and put that knowledge into
practice run dozens of tests and
ultimately discover that was one change
that made the biggest difference take a
look at this example from nature they
use 17 different landing pages and set
up an a/b test for each one in the end
the change that makes a biggest
difference and increase in conversion
from 2% to 19% was the only difference
between the tested landing page and the
original landing
context your calls to action after water
test there are a lot of different
elements that can make all that it in
fact even a smaller search engine to
make the biggest of differences it's up
to you to find out what that change
could be first
there's your page layout have a play
with it
see how it affects your conversion rate
for example with the placement of your
product or service copy or the location
of your call-to-action remember when we
talked about heat maps and eye tracking
software a little early on here is where
that information will come in really
handy check to see if your visitors
attention is going to the part of your
page you want it to and if not make
changes to the layout of your pages and
web site next there are the colors you
use on your website we should also be
tested color can have a huge
psychological impact on people without
them even realizing technology use
including call-to-action buttons
backgrounds and so on in fact it's
recommended that websites are created in
grayscale to avoid being influenced by a
color building a new font headlines are
usually one of the first things a
visible region they visit a page or
website there are a few different things
to check you the most important one is
the wording of your head try out
different headlines we'll see which one
attracts the most attention for new
visitors other things that you can test
or the placement of your headline and
the font you use including the size and
color they'll all have a copy from your
page that means considering - it might
be that you need to add more contextual
call to action like nature air just
before or maybe you should change your
paragraph and add more bullet points
actually need to change the word and
entirely remove entire parts of it's too
long add different testimonials and the
ones currently there and so on the
visuals you use on your website are also
very influential images videos and other
visual context make a big engine but try
different wants to test a performer and
then
next we have the call to action which
again is extremely important we can make
a huge dip there are several things you
can testing including the wording you
use the color and shape of the book and
what is its position on the page
basically if I put earlier everything
from your web pages can be tested in
just a matter of identifying the most
important elements and prioritizing the
test you're going to run I want to give
you an example of how important the
call-to-action button you and how it's
evolved for the biggest e-commerce
website Amazon if you look at the Amazon
Add to Cart button on the late 19th
you'll notice it's very different from
what it looks like today in fact today
is Add to Cart button would most likely
not have worked back in the 19th an
Amazon would not have gotten to the
point where they are now if they have
used it then that would be because in
the 90s people are still very new to
online shopping and even to the Internet
Journal they have no reason to trust
online businesses and I didn't really
know how online shop worked so they
needed reassurance what Ana conduct is
give them those reassurances within
their call to action button something as
you can see they made sure to point out
that even if a visitor add something to
the car that doesn't mean they're
automatically buying it and in fact they
will be able to remove the item later on
if they so choose because yes there was
some of those things they were afraid of
in this day so we would just buy stuff
by mistake just by clicking on the wrong
button next they also made George tell
their visitors as shopping with them is
completely safe notice how they
underlined the word guaranteed and put
it in a different color so that their
visitors will be assured that shopping
with Amazon in space now though the Add
to Cart button is completely different
more people than ever are using online
shopping and the Amazon customers know
that they can
ask the e-commerce Giants not to steal
from them nowadays customers are not
bothered by safety guarantees or
anything of the store especially not
from Amazon rather they just want to buy
what they need as soon as possible so
they can get it to live it as soon as
possible they don't even want to be
bothered with entering their credit card
information or they're delivered it so
Amazon now gives them the chance to buy
a socket they like with one-click
personalization is one of the biggest
buzz words in marketing right now
websites
Easter's and even bricks and mortar
schools are increasingly leveraging
personalization to keep people around
for longer and most importantly buying
more but how does personalization
correlate with conversion
personalization can have incredible
effects on conversion there are many
studies that back it up on very
interesting statistic resembles shows
that businesses that employ
personalization on their website
actually see an impressive 14% increase
in SM I was kind of $0.68 of companies
say the personalization is it topped our
article and well it makes perfect sense
after all if you're visiting a website
but you're not resonating within user
content easily now quite likely to
abandon that website and look for a
better solution for your needs if on the
other hand you see content is highly
relevant to you
you're my unlikely to spend a longer
time on the website visit multiple pages
in one visit and download something
computer form or even buy something from
that website
in a nutshell personalization improves
the unique thing and at the end of the
day the goal of CRO is to improve user
experience so they can ultimately
improve your conversion rate after
implementing more personalization on
your website there are two main ways to
go about either manually or
automatically using a specialized tool
but in order to personalize your website
expectable
you first need to know all of the
different types of people that you're
targeting now I've have improperly pair
five content specifically for them have
a great example of this in action their
product offer solutions for different
departments and as you can see in the
screenshot they have a marketing hub
whose there is towards the marketer then
they have a sale hub of various useful
sales tools and finally they also offer
custom service possible how exactly does
this affect their website content
you've ever visited the HubSpot blog you
might have noticed that it's not a unit
on book rather is a collection of blocks
each designed to target a different part
of their target as you can see here they
have four different blocks a marketing
blog to help them catch all those
markets they want to target FL blog to
help them target salespeople and in
service blog for those working in
customer service
finally beyond all of these targeted
blocks they also have a news and trend
book which is designed to attract a
wider audience that hopefully will
navigate to other more targeted blocks
from their web
you
yes as you can see here new subscriber
block you can choose what kinds of
topics you're interested in trap they
also offer you the slack and messenger
subscription options so that's a
different type of CRO methods that their
use introduces and subscribers than
personalization now how can you to start
implementing personalization technique
through your company website it's not
the first time I brought up the
importance of defining audience personas
and it probably won't be the last
although generating that when talking
about HubSpot multiple targeted walk the
first step in the process of
implementing personalization techniques
if it is stablish and define your
customer or audience persona it's
important to understand that these are
audience depends on your work
particularly the traffic that you're
getting to your website after all this
is who you want
couger in department but who exactly
forms your audience create several
audience to phone as many as you need
and as detailed
these are some of the things that you
should include in your audience - phoner
demographics who are they where they
from and how old are they
what is their gender it can even give
them a fictional nature help how do they
come to your website and what do they
expect to get out of it the more you
understand their motivation the better
you can improve that customer journey
can user experience
and what is their customer behavior like
what do they need to convert the
impulsive I'm ready to buy it first time
or maybe know their opposites came to
perform lots of research reading lots of
proof before making a buying decision
the more detail you can go into the
session the prevents your going to all
this detour it helps you think of them
as real people which in turn allows you
to better imagine what their motivations
for their expectations are and what
they're most likely to behave like you
can put your clothes in their shoes and
try to ascertain what their customer
journeys are on your website what the
user experience is really like for them
and what they prefer to see instead am i
putting yourself in their shoes and
truly understanding their customer
journey the more you'll be able to
personalize it on your website
pop-up can be annoying I'm not going to
deny that but as much of people complain
about them they're also very effective
at their job but you can actually
improve your results and pull out simply
by personalizing you now several ways to
do so for example one simple way is to
mention visitors name right in the
pop-up like in this example from options
using someone's first name get their
attention so they're more likely to read
through your pop-up and the more people
read your pop-ups the more likely they
will take action another way to
personalize pop-ups will boost
yourselves if the show personalized
upselling offer when someone adds
something to their cart for example
whenever you go to the Go Pro online
store and add a product to your car a
pop-up will immediately appear showing
the current items in your cart along
with a selection of related and popular
products that you might also like to buy
this is such a simple and yet such an
effective strategies that ecommerce
store all you need to do is further
entice your customers with more products
they might be interested in more
relevant to them and the product they
already have in a cart the best if
people are browsing your online store or
even a gas pump into their car you can
give them an extra boost to make their
decision to buy for a simple pop-up that
creates urgency for example something
like harrowing they're only two more
dresses left or this offer is only
available today by now can give
customers but push they need to buy from
you if you have a worldwide audience as
we're creating different versions of
your website depending on where it's
being accessed when you create this type
of dynamic website if I'm on access is
it from Pacific country they could for
example see content in their own
language but also any exclusive offers
for that specific region the example if
you were to visit Viacom you will notice
that you get multiple options of
websites to visit depending on your
location the locations that have online
shopping clearly marked as such
depending on which location YouTube you
will see different products and awful
local brick-and-mortar darcel as well as
pricing in your current and your
countries currently another way to go
about it is to do it automatically for
example the food network will
automatically send you to a UK website
if you log in from outside the US even
if you're entering the dot comics
function in your browser there's some
powerful personalization tools out there
they can help you implement some
impressive personalization techniques on
your website for example a
personalization tool like pure 360 will
change the content being displayed on
your website based on users past
browsing habits and their past purchases
just like Amazon does it if for example
they spent a lot of time looking at
shoes on your website then they can see
something like this when they visit your
website therefore promoting exactly the
type of product that you want them to
see first-class you can further improve
your conversions and sales by using the
Amazon system so recommended and related
products on each of your product pages
to encourage people to buy more the
example seamless message might make
visitors take a look and see what else
they should buy with a product they're
currently brown then these two options
give them even more shopping options as
well as providing upselling
opportunities to further this type of
personalization is a huge part of Amazon
success together with their frequent
personalized emails that focuses solely
on promoting products that are relevant
to you based on your past viewed items
and your past purchase CRO is an
essential part of a growing business
going traffic is simply not enough you
need to also get that traffic to take
action you need to generate leads
consistently
and the best most scalable way to do
this is your conversion rate
optimisation you need to use CRO to
continue improving your website and
boosting your result time and time again
because as I mentioned earlier CIO is a
continuous process something that you
need to keep doing regularly in order to
improve time and time again thank you
very much everyone for joining us and
thanks again to Lila Bullock
thank you sorry marce dynamic wonderful
to be here I really appreciate it thank
you
[Music]